i'm trevor phillips this is common
ground where each week we look for
agreement on hot button issues dividing
the nation
tonight
welcome to the generation game or better
the generation blame game this
government will not sit idly by whilst
there is a risk that some in our country
might be set so far back
they might never recover i don't think
we'll
survive
another winter winter
without something being done had the
triple lock in place for a long time
which protects pensioners because they
are among the most vulnerable in our
society get my own place through the
mortgage system is
it's just not an option right now
so yeah hopefully down the line you know
it's much more achievable but right now
realistically it's not an option home
ownership
is overwhelmingly concentrated amongst
the over 65s those who are able to buy
in an era when housing was much cheaper
this week pensioners learned that
they'll trouser an inflation-busting pay
rise and they didn't need to strike
we've earned it they say frankly what
with some having to choose between
heating and eating we need every penny
not fair say the next generation you're
sitting pretty in properties that earn
more money every year than we do we'll
be funding your pensions with extra
taxes and paying your debt for decades
our choice in this clash of generations
who needs help the most
or is there a deal to be done
in the next 30 minutes two passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
with me tonight the former pensions
minister baroness ros altman and the
economist uh g van sander who has worked
in government for the treasury and also
for the department of work and pensions
and i'm going to ask both of you and
also our viewers tonight to think of me
as a kind of journalistic mick jagger
completely ageless i have no interest uh
personal interest here
roz let me start with you
pensioners are going to get a 10
rise people in work will struggle to get
3
um and most of that is going to be wiped
out by inflation is that fair
well
pensioners are
being promised that their pension will
increase in line with
either inflation or earnings growth most
likely inflation
now last year because earnings growth
was so high
pensioners were stripped of the promised
protections
that the manifesto
in 2019
said they would be entitled to and even
the poor
yes but it was particularly the earnings
element of it because the government
didn't like the fact that earnings were
going up so much it suddenly said well
we're only going to increase
in line with september's
consumer price index which was 3.1 now
that has got to last pensioners until
next april clearly
they need to catch up and just giving
them
an increase in line with inflation is
hardly inflation busting it's matching
inflation after a year in which they
have fallen way behind but they will get
in the end they will get the 10 but even
without that they'll be getting they're
still getting winter fuel allowance
they'll be getting other kinds of
benefits won't they well that's always
been our system and the problem we have
is that we we tend to focus on what the
change in the state pension might be
each year rather than what the level is
we pay the lowest state pension in the
entire developed world
the oecd every year
does its uh surveys and it
puts the uk at the bottom
of the pension pile yes there are some
very well-off pensioners but if they're
living just on the state pension
they are not very well off and there are
millions who are either in poverty or on
the cusp of it okay so even um
essentially patients even the in the
best of all worlds are going to end up
with what nine and a half thousand a
year not all
older people are wealthy
and
for the most part there's a moral point
they are getting what they've worked for
what why would you want to deprive them
of the fun fruits of their labor i
wouldn't want to deprive them at all i
think rosa's pointed out there are some
pensioners living in poverty about two
million pensions in poverty today that's
about one in six now for me that's two
million more pensions in the pods there
should be there should be no pension in
but we should also remember there are
one in six pensioners in poverty one in
three children are in poverty and they
also don't have any choice about why
that is the case and in this case ten
years of social security cuts a
low-income family with two kids had a
cut about 2 000 pounds per family and
also during this pandemic and now
there's cost of living crisis that's
getting worse 2.6 million kids going
hungry there should be no kids going
hungry so moisture is not that actually
perched or shouldn't be helped they
should but we should also be looking at
where there's a lot more harm going on
that's particularly around low-income
children in this country right but this
is uh all relative isn't isn't uh
your point i guess
that
while
nothing is perfect
the government's got a limited amount of
money and where it is putting the
emphasis
is frankly to help the older person with
the inflation rises whereas on the other
hand students essentially uh having to
pay a bit more relatively speaking for
their loans they are indeed we should
remember that actually students in this
country especially graduates do face
unfair taxes because of decisions by
this government the average graduate
will now face a marginal tax rate of
42.25 percent 20
of income tax 13.25 on national
insurance and 9 in student loan
repayments even worse we come into this
cost of living crisis they've now got
another 200 pound tax rise because the
chance of lowered the student loan
repayment threshold that's cancelling
out the cost of living payment on the
other side so certainly they certainly
need more help in this cost of living
christ that's not what we're seeing from
this government can we agree at least
one thing that
whether one thinks it's the right
decision or not in the last couple of
years policy has tilted a bit at least
towards supporting
the older rather than the younger part
of the population is that a reasonable
proposition i'm not sure given that the
state pension
earnings link and the earnings
protection for the pension credit which
is the means-tested uh top-up to the
state pension for those who have even
less
than the state pension pays
uh
that
protection was taken away last year so
or this year rather than last year it
was announced last year but it's four
this year
so
yes i think
the government has made some attempts to
protect
pensioners partly because pensioners can
never earn more
there's nothing they can do to improve
their situation if they're relying on
the state pension and nothing else and
so many are
then they're completely stuck and
dependent on the rest of society they
can't look forward to a better future
and indeed many of them may not be alive
in that better future that's that's the
probability but what i really
find troubling is this idea of trying to
pit one generation
against another we're a society and
certainly i think our society is based
on the idea that we support each other
the young
are looked after by their parents
as they are growing up
and then
elderly relatives are looked after by
younger generations i don't want to lose
that well i want to come to this point
but is that the way it feels to you as a
this sort of happy co-dependency i wish
it was right i wish it was the case that
actually we're looking after pensioners
and looking after young people that's
like clearly not been the case for the
past 10 years you know after the last 10
years we've had the triple lock where
we've had pensions rising at the highest
of either earnings inflation or 2.5
percent on the other side those social
security payments especially for
low-income families either frozen or cut
in real terms that was a two thousand
pound cut i was talking about earlier
even this latest package this cost of
living package a pensioner a low-income
pensioner will get
1150 pounds a low-income family with two
kids will only get 850 pounds if you
look at what's happening with energy
bills a low-income pension has just
about enough to get the increase in
energy bills from that cost of living
package a low-income family with two
kids over 500 pounds short still
so it's not the case that actually have
had this happy codependency i wish that
had have been the case i wish both
pensioners and those of younger
generation are doing well but that
certainly has not been the case for a
very long time and at least since 2010.
well let's at least agree that actually
this is where people think we'd like to
get to whether it's realizing that way
we'll discuss doing this program um what
i want to do is to look at both each
side of this question in turn and
starting with i guess a position that
that you take roz let's um
let's think about what will government
has actually done
there are lots of poor old people older
people um but by and large
not that many in this country are
destitute
is there a problem in
what you call protection
of
the older generation that we do it
indiscriminately everybody gets the
winter fuel everybody gets the state
pension unless they have somehow opted
out of it everybody gets the uh where
there's free travel and so on is that
right
well that's how our system works that's
the you know that is the basis on which
national insurance works
everybody pays contributions throughout
their working life
and much of that
is due to pay for a
basic state pension not a king's ransom
by any means that will help them survive
when they can no longer work and pay in
those contributions
now
what we are seeing is
a confusion
between basic support you know as as you
said
even the full new state pension is only
around nine and a half thousand pounds a
year anyone in work
on average earnings is earning possibly
up to three times that much and many are
earning a lot more
so
the fact that we've caught up since 2010
is actually a success
in social policy because pensioners were
prior to that far more likely to be in
poverty than they are now
and you know a civilized society can
sometimes be measured by how they look
after the vulnerable in particular the
old
and if we don't look after pensioners
we're not looking after the vulnerable
sections of society but you see the
point i'm making there you know a lot of
people of a certain age who are
mortgage-free they
have a relatively comfortable life and
we'll talk about this a bit later on
they can give
help to their children in various ways
should they really be getting
the same benefits from the state as
somebody who is depending on that nine
and nine thousand six hundred are there
about what really
um
i think would make enormous sense
is
for example the extra freebie add-ons
that politicians have added as gimmicks
over the years for you know almost
bribing pensioners so you know within
the last 20 30 years like the winter
fuel payment
that was meant to be temporary and it
was tax-free
clearly worth far more
to a very well-off pensioner
than to
the average and lower income lowest
income pensioners why shouldn't that be
taxable why do we need these bits and
pieces of free tax-free
extra benefits so i would
fully support rolling those extra
payments you know you've got a a
christmas bonus okay you know there are
bits and pieces that cost a lot of money
but they're they're not taxable i i'm
going to i'm going to come to this bit
of add-ons uh
a little later but even what do you
think about this issue about
the universality of it
i think in general speaking actually you
want to ensure that people have buy-in
to the system so universal payments are
generally speaking a good way to do it
incredibly well targeted if you like
social security systems like those in
the united states actually end up being
much less generous because not enough
people feel like they have buy into the
system they don't support it they don't
want to spend the tax on it and that's
completely understandable i have no
issue with the universality of payments
i would say also then yes do you also
want to tax it more on the other side
but you have two choices when it comes
to targeting you kind of just try and
hit the people who are most in need and
then you're going to miss some who are
in need or you have a much wider net
that makes you catch everyone who needs
it and i personally am much more in
favor of the latter i want to put
another point to you to ross um
is the situation that we've got
sustainable i mean one of the things
that i'm particularly interested in is
that what um
there are various names for it but what
people
call the age dependency ratio that is
say the number of people
who in work who have to support a single
pensioner and
it used to be much larger that there
were four people in for every pension
now it's more like two and a half
they're about uh workers for every
pensioner this can't go on because
ultimately what's going to happen is
that there's going to be one
youngish person supporting more than one
pensioner well
um if you look at the economic arguments
here
basically
as long as you are in a growing economy
where productivity is improving and if
you can encourage
longer working lives which has been a
big part of um government policy
although it hasn't been as nearly as
successful as one would want and the
pandemic has undone some of the progress
we've made but if you can help people
work part-time in later life if they're
well enough and of course not everyone
is
and if they if they want to
then that itself will address some of
the demographic challenges but at the
end of the day
all western countries are grappling with
the demographics we had a baby boomer
generation
who never had enough children to offer
them the support that
previous generations would have had that
should have been planned for much better
than it has been
but i don't think that
uh we're heading for a kind of
one-to-one scenario china's for example
is in a much better state than we are
yeah and
japan okay let's talk about um uh your
case here chief
let me ask you this
young people these days start life
frankly with a better deal they're bet
they have better health they have warmer
homes and their parents and grandparents
better education
than
their parents um isn't it a bit entitled
to start complaining that you're being
done down i don't think so especially
when there are 2.6 million kids going
hungry in terms of a better education we
actually face a graduate takes or labor
market where you need to get a degree to
get a good job what was available to
previous generations where you left
school had enough to pay the bills and
enough to buy the houses is something
that we don't have we also have a
housing market that of course is not
working so the 20 years before the
pandemic house price is up by over a
hundred percent wages only increased by
20 that's why our home ownership rates
are declining and on top of that of
course that unfair tax system that
penalizes us and when you put all that
together that graduate takes all labor
market that unfair housing situation and
punitive taxation you actually have a
system where my generation can't afford
to put down routes and start families
that are birthing this country down by
almost 15 percent in the last five years
one hundred thousand fewer people that's
probably a rich country not expected a
hundred thousand fewer babies who are
expecting over five years than just
about wealth and i think roswell's right
to talk about a great nation as one
where we actually look after our most
vulnerable i think a great country also
looks to its future and that's not where
we are right now am i being unfair to
say that there's a bit of sense of
entitlement going on here
um
i don't think you can generalize in that
way and actually i do think that many
young people understandably look back at
what they
perceive was happening in previous
generations
and sometimes forget for example that
only 10 percent of our generation
had any chance of going to university
they would have started work at 15 or 16
in most cases so by the time they were
into their late 20s they'd been working
for you know 13 15 years
now the fact that younger people can't
afford to get on the housing ladder
until later
isn't necessarily a sign of failure
given the history what is a sign of
failure
is the
lack of housing supply you know the
government hasn't built enough homes
that's not the fault of young people and
it's not the fault of old people it's
the way the system has failed to plan
for the housing needs that we have but
let me pick up to pick up this point
about housing juventus
many young people actually benefit from
older persons people's wealth
the bank of mum and dad
gets them through uni
the bank of mum and dead dad helps them
to buy their first home i read today the
bank of mum and dad is the ninth biggest
mortgage provider
in the country uh one of the biggest
investment firms says that gifts were
behind more than half of the purchases
of homes by 35 year olds so actually
the there may be some unfairnesses in
this system but young people are
actually benefiting because the old
their parents or grandparents basically
help them out well the young people are
the rich parents like the problem for my
generation not necessarily just rich but
ordinary parents the young people in
this country our determinant how well
we're going to do life is because of
housing and other issues how rich our
parents are rather than how hard we work
that is the problem we spoke earlier
about whether or not we feel entitled no
we want a fair shot at a decent life i
want every member of my generation to be
able to work hard and have a decent life
but as things stand unless as like you
say mum and dad is there to help out
with the deposit actually you're not
really going to get on that housing
ladder a half of under 35s need help
from the bank of mum and dad so actually
what determines our life chances is a
happy stance of birth i want every
single young person to have a decent
shot at a good life
okay the same can apply
to the older people i think what we're
identifying here is this
fact that our country is
split there are enormous differentials
at every age group
and those
so-called rich pensioners
are not all pensioners there are some
extraordinarily poor pensioners many of
whom never had a chance to buy their own
home either by the way
and there are some very low income
younger people but there are also
some much better off young people as
well
so lumping every generation together
ignores the fact that we have an
unusually
disparate
income
distribution and wealth distribution
across our country and in terms of
sharing that around as trevor was
describing families are happy to share
what they do have with their
uh offspring with with younger
generations
but
in many cases the older generations
who built up what they've got
never also had the chances that that
young people now have if i may write i
would agree with you that there
shouldn't be any poor pensions there are
of course divides the issue is about
where we're sitting on the average right
and on the average at our age for
millennials our home ownership rates are
half of what they were for the baby
boomers the other problem we have is
that financial security isn't really
about income anymore it's actually about
wealth i agree with you that older
people worked really hard to put down
the deposit on their house but what they
didn't earn was a huge increase in house
prices we've seen since then so it's not
at all about the fact that i see the old
versus the young it's about on average
my generation doesn't have the same
opportunities and that's why we're
delaying childbirth it's why we can't
get on the housing ladder well as i say
if you start work later then obviously
you would expect home ownership later
but
just because an older person is living
in a house that's gone up in value
doesn't help them be able to afford to
live you know we're still talking about
pensioners who struggle to pay just the
basic bills they pay a much higher
proportion of their income on just food
and eating they don't go on holidays
they don't have
tech and they don't don't have all
different types of entertainment they're
many of them just at home
let's see if we can find our way towards
some common ground because i think you
know you both agree that actually there
is virtue in universality
not because it's fair but because it
will persuade everybody everybody to buy
into the system
but i wonder if actually
um hearing you both whether there is a
slightly different way to think about
this and that
we have invented if you like what i
suppose economists have called
age-related transfers in some way you
know that we decide uh that younger
people will have
this benefit or and older people will
have that benefit but maybe we need to
focus more on um wealth transfers
particularly which are related to what
you already have that actually we
coming back to the point i was asking
you about ross
is it
right that everybody over a certain age
should get a certain benefit and indeed
in some
we don't have child benefit in the way
we used to the people under a certain
age should also
all get the same benefit and that we
should stop thinking of age as a as a
way of defining
what the state should give you
i think you're heading towards a kind of
minimum guaranteed income for everybody
um and i mean that that is a whole
nother discussion and there are lots of
economic arguments both for
and against that the main issue with
that is the one of incentives and what
happens at the margin if you were
already getting a certain level of
income
uh
why would you bother to try and improve
your lot or make yourself better off in
future if you know you can fall back on
that anyway what do you think
well i think actually we do need to
think about
that sense of
what should everyone have to live a
decent life i think that's the first
starting point and that counts for both
the pensioners who as ros has said can't
generally speaking work and for young
people in work as well and that's where
i think we have slightly fallen down we
do live in a country that is incredibly
divided low and high paid jobs in low
and high wage places and actually you
need to increase and make sure they have
enough to live on and for young people
and for non-pensions in particular it's
really about enough in-work social
security payments you know we live in a
country where 70 of kids in poverty are
in working households so you need to
make sure that everyone does have that
chance opportunity and a good life all
right well look let me let me um let me
try and see if we can make some progress
on actual possibilities so uh coming
back to one of the things you said
earlier on ros and i want to put this to
you
what do you think about the idea of
doing something about these add-ons uh
you know let me reveal myself i i have
i have the right to have a free
transport uh in the city where i live
it's london i don't take it because i
think it's ludicrous but
should we just not have that kind of
thing because these are
bribes aren't they
well i actually have no issue with kind
of those add-on benefits right i
actually also think we should live in a
country where more people use more
public transport because the reason why
young people can't get ahead is it
because pensioners are getting the
winter fuel allowance or because
pensioners have the triple lock it's
because there haven't been enough on the
other side so i personally but it would
help if you weren't bunging all this
money at old people well that's
extremely like a singular pot whereas
actually there's a lot better ways to
get the cash that we need you know we've
seen huge increase in wealth during this
pandemic the average billionaire we
think has seen the an average increase
of wealth over 500 million 15 percent
more billionaires as well there's places
to get that wealth i don't that we have
to take away the winds of fuel or
downwards or indeed your own bus pass
trevor okay um
ross let me try to try one with you this
is part of the program where i basically
say
ah i've got a good idea and everybody
says that's rubbish so let me put this
let me put
this one to you um
is it time to think about
uh the extent to which
uh families hoard wealth should we be
making wealth hoarding i.e keeping the
property
because you want to pass it on on all of
that a bit less profitable by limits
greater limits on
what inheritance you can pass on free
well
that
is
something that sounds incredibly
attractive
and to be honest given the bank of
england's policies
since 2009 which i believe
have
extol extremely inflated wealth
inequality you know they they are partly
responsible for the conversation we're
having now
whereby
those who already owned assets in 2009
have done
extraordinarily well including those who
may have owned homes despite the fact
that interest rates have come down
younger people have been unable to
afford house prices partly because
the bank of england's policies printing
money to buy assets to inflate asset
prices have driven house prices up so
much that's combined with the supply but
if
if we were to have a wealth tax for
example one or two percent a year like
other countries do
maybe that's something that would
allow for redistribution but you have to
be very careful with these things steven
okay
would you be attracted by that very
briefly i think look let's take a wealth
tax instead of the we have the 12
billion for national insurance okay you
get 5 billion by a capital gains tax
reform 5 billion from taxing every
single transaction city and 2 billion
from a mansion tax there are certain
wealth taxes that can absolutely work
but it is like a case-by-case basis
well this is very very helpful i think
we're getting we've actually almost got
somewhere it feels to me um that we're
in a place where we all agree uh
contrary to what i suggested to you that
we shouldn't uh attack universal
benefits that we need to keep them going
but there are ways in which we can
redistribute particularly wealth and
maybe
not concentrate so much on income
maybe a wealth tax maybe inheritance tax
and the last thing i think why which
i've heard from both of you which is
that some of this could have been
avoided if we looked forward a bit more
and that is the role of politics
absolutely
this is very exciting it seems to me
like we have got some common ground
thank you both very much indeed uh stay
with us
we'll all we'll have all of today's news
coming up after the break
[Music]